Over a decade of Marvel movie magic, 21 films
in the MCU, dozens of Easter eggs, and hundreds
of minutes of action and emotion — it has
all led up to this moment: the release of
Avengers: Endgame.
Ahead of Endgame's theatrical debut, reviews
for the superhero ensemble started hitting
the internet.
Critics near and far raced to let their thoughts
about Endgame be heard — and you'll want
to lend them your ear.
Here's what the critics on Rotten Tomatoes
are saying about Avengers: Endgame.
Don't worry: you're entering a spoiler-free
zone!
There's a lot riding on Avengers: Endgame
to be a worthy successor to Avengers: Infinity
War and a capstone to three phases of the
MCU so far.
Thankfully, Endgame seems to have doubly succeeded.
Critics say it pays off everything within
itself and much that preceded it: risks of
past movies, bets the heroes make here, the
lengthy run time, the stakes and storylines,
the plot we won't spoil — everything.
Mashable's Angie Han wrote:
"The bet pays off.
The story feels more organic this time, the
emotions more earned, and the interpersonal
dynamics richer and more lived-in."
Den of Geek called the film "a totally triumphant
payoff," while Susana Polo of Polygon said
"there's nothing Endgame sets up that it doesn't
pay off."
Said David Sims of The Atlantic:
"The film earns its length not by overstuffing
the frame with opulent action, but by slowing
things down and basking in the charisma of
its ensemble.
[...] Thanos's demand for a dramatic ending
in Infinity War pays off here in all the right
ways."
Russ Fischer at Birth.Movies.Death. agreed:
"Rather than closing things down, Endgame
opens everything up.
This is a genre film with layers of overlapping
Big Ideas, character conflicts that could
be flat-out ridiculous if handled with less
skill, and deep in-jokes featuring dozens
of costumed characters […] Ultimately, Endgame
is an entire movie of payoffs.
It plays off and completes thoughts begun
in Age of Ultron and Civil War, and even in
comics."
If you thought Avengers: Infinity War was
heartbreaking, you apparently have a big storm
coming with Avengers: Endgame.
Critics are advising fans to pack some hankies
and wear waterproof mascara when they head
out to see the film, as it's packed with tear-jerking
emotions of all sorts.
Hey, it even reportedly made Captain America
himself, Chris Evans, cry six times.
INSIDER's Kirsten Acuna wants moviegoers to
hit the theater prepared:
"Bust out the tissues, Marvel fans.
Avengers: Endgame is going to make you laugh,
cheer aloud, tear up multiple times, and cry.
By the film's end, there were audible sniffles
throughout INSIDER's 10 AM press screening
Tuesday morning.
Endgame is an emotional punch straight to
the gut.
[...] You're going to be too emotionally distraught
by the film's ending to really nitpick at
anything in Endgame."
Viewers won't weep exclusively out of sadness,
though.
As Rosie Fletcher and Richard Jordan at Den
of Geek wrote in their joint review:
"At times Endgame is heartbreaking — expect
to cry.
But there are certain scenes that border on
the euphoric; certain character moments, surprises
and reveals that hit so hard in the heart
and the head that it feels like you're MCU-drunk."
Even Richard Roeper of the Chicago Sun-Times
couldn't help but be moved by Endgame:
"It's a serious contender for the crown and
it's the undisputed champion when it comes
to emotional punch.
[...] Avengers: Endgame is as emotionally
affecting as any Marvel movie has ever been."
Okay, so we know the movie will probably make
you cry – but that doesn't mean the movie
is a sob-fest from start to finish.
Critics have indicated that Endgame features
plenty of the MCU's trademark humor, which
helps steady the sentimentality.
Jake Kleinman of Inverse explained:
"Thor delivers some of the best jokes in Endgame
(sometimes without saying a word)."
The Washington Post's Michael O'Sullivan concurred,
saying,
"As high as the stakes are in Endgame, it
is also a very funny movie."
It seems one of the movie's most prominent
strong points is its ability to mix emotion
with comedy — and avoid tipping too far
to one side.
As The Guardian's Peter Bradshaw wrote,
"The sheer enjoyment and fun that it delivers,
the pure exotic spectacle, are irresistible,
as is its insouciant way of combining the
serious and the comic.
Without the comedy, the drama would not be
palatable.
Yet without the earnest, almost childlike
belief in the seriousness of what is at stake,
the funny stuff would not work either."
National Review critic Kyle Smith might have
said it best when he wrote, "[A] somber aura
gives Avengers: Endgame its gravitas, but
the movie is also funny, rousing, and, above
all, endearing."
Where there are lovers, there are haters — or,
in this case, people who didn't fall completely
head over heels for the feature.
Bold and beautiful as it evidently is, the
film still isn't immune from critique.
Though the vast majority of reviewers basically
gave Endgame full marks, a few critics took
a more, well, critical approach to the film.
Forbes senior contributor Scott Mendelson
wrote that Endgame is "flawed" and feels as
if it "copied" certain beats of Infinity War,
though it's still entertaining and ties up
the threads of the MCU nicely:
"It doesn't make a ton of internal sense,
suffers from narrative claustrophobia, and
the action leaves a little to be desired.
[...] Avengers: Endgame is a merely okay MCU
movie … [but] there is grace in its failings."
Donald Clarke of The Irish Times argued that
Endgame "spends too long wallowing in its
own pomposity" and is "short on fun."
Christian Long at Glide Magazine called it
a "subversive, compelling, and thoroughly
unsatisfying" film that "chooses to rely on
vacuous fan service instead of taking the
time to put any real heart into its storytelling."
One certified rotten review came from Globe
and Mail's Barry Hertz, who wrote, "The entire
endeavour loses any sense of emotional stakes
or general meaning beyond the deliverance
of crass fan-service and incomprehensible
visuals."
"Ouch."
It seems that for every fault one could find
in Avengers: Endgame, ten times the amount
of merits exist.
Sure, a handful of critics weren't roused
by the superhero ensemble — and that's A-okay.
But far more were moved enough to exalt it
as a true achievement and stamp it with perfect
or near-perfect scores.
Why?
According to Germain Lussier with io9, the
film is
"everything you've ever dreamed a Marvel movie
could be" — and then some.
Inverse's Jake Kleinman wrote that the film
definitely delivers on its promises of big
action and bigger heart, with its third act
feeling, quote, "unlike anything we've seen
before" in the history of the MCU:
"As the movie finally ended, I felt different,
almost as if I was glowing like Brie Larson's
Captain Marvel.
The result of 11 years of world-building has
arrived, and it feels like nothing will be
the same again."
In his review of Endgame, Nick Johnston at
Vanyaland said that the film is everything
a fan could want, and feels like an actual
ending to the story, writing,
"It doesn’t feel like a teaser for another
movie later on down the line [...] it’s
content with satisfying you, the devoted,
in the here and now."
The Salt Lake Tribune's Sean P. Means offered
a similar analysis, writing,
"Avengers: Endgame delivers everything Marvel
fans will enjoy and not much that they expect
[…] Earth's mightiest heroes fulfill their
promise, in an installment that takes a decade
of superhero storytelling and ties it together
into an astounding, emotional conclusion."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.